now we turn to the financial challenges
that many black americans face
it's part of our coverage of black
history month a new survey by ariel
investments and charles schwab reveals
how black investors continue to lag
behind their white counterparts
in building wealth while 71 percent of
white americans say they invest in socks
just 55 percent of black americans do
and when it comes to saving the survey
found black americans put away 300
fewer dollars every month than white
americans melody hobson is the co-ceo
and president of aerial investments and
joins us now melody good morning
great to have you thanks for being here
great to see you a couple of things
really struck me in the survey the
the first and obviously the most
alarming is that the black family's
median and mean wealth
is less than 15 of white families i mean
that's
a stunning statistic but i was also
really surprised to see
that african-american participation in
the stock market is at its
lowest level in the 20 years of this
survey
is the pandemic playing a role in that
well this was certainly one of the most
disheartening things about the research
that we've done that we've come
full circle from when i first started
doing this survey
in 1998 till now we're actually at a
lower level
of stock market participation than that
time 1998
we peaked in the early zeros with
participation around 74
but this is a real setback the pandemic
certainly has had a lot to do with that
we've seen a period where the black
economic condition
has been really challenged african
americans have been hit
much harder in this pandemic than white
americans you see that with just the
unemployment rate itself
when we did this survey we were hovering
almost close to 11
of black unemployment versus around six
for whites
so that was one part of the story and
certainly we've had to borrow from our
401k
radar savings defer student loans a
whole bunch of issues that kept us
from being able to invest does that mean
that wide wealth gap is getting even
wider melody
absolutely and the thing is when you
compound these differences over time
we're talking about giant differences
when it comes to saving for retirement
or the the ability to pass on money to
heirs
uh you know at death so these are giant
differences that
we really need to address because they
have big implications
for all of society this is not just a
black
issue to the extent that african
americans have not
saved or invested in the same degree or
to the same degree
as our white counterparts we will find
ourselves being a burden on society
that means higher taxes for everyone
there are real implications here
yeah it makes me sad to hear that melody
you said there are some bright spots in
the survey show that
younger black americans are investing in
the stock market but you also say
caution here caution
so here's the good news there's there is
hope just so you know
and that is when we looked at african
americans under 40
they're tracking with their white
counterparts across all
income levels that's a great story so
we're playing catch up
we're actually talking about the stock
market around the dinner table
and that is a very very good sign last
year
african americans were three times more
likely to invest
in the stock market than their white
counterparts those under the age of 40.
now the watch out we're talking about a
frothy market right now
the market is has yet again crossed
another all-time high
yesterday so we want to make sure people
are playing the long game here
that they're they're not thinking about
the short term and they're investing for
the long term
and they don't run out of the market at
the first sign of trouble i was raised
in a home melody where we didn't talk
about money because my mom said it's
impolite yeah we should we should really
rethink that shouldn't we in the
conversations that we have about money
especially in black families where the
wealth gap is so is so wide
that is changing right now in real time
gail and i am so happy to see it
we asked people did you talk about the
top stock market when you were growing
up
10 of african americans said that they
did a third
almost almost 40 of african americans
right now
say they are talking about the stock
market and money
around the table in their homes today
that is a big jump
another big change melody is that you
are about to become the chairman of the
board of starbucks in a few weeks
the first black woman ever to have a
forecast
by the way my starbucks name is nick
anything you can do to
increase the delivery of my orders of
lattes thank you
but but how did that's um this is a
momentous this is a momentous moment
because
blacks continue to be significantly
underrepresented in boardrooms and at
ceo positions it's a big deal melody
hobson
this is a crazy thing in 2021
i will be the only black woman chair of
a fortune 500 company
that is not now i think i'm talented and
smart
but i think there are some others that
are equally talented and this makes no
sense
ross brewer will be the only black woman
ceo
of a fortune 500 company there will only
be
five black people running fortune 500
companies in this country
something is wrong with this math we
have to do
better how do you change it melody
quickly
there has to be more inclusion from
every level of the company
pipeline people focus on but i told them
focus on the c-suite
look at the board and make sure these
numbers track the demographics
of our society you have to set targets
melody you're right it is nuts but can
we just take a second and say you are a
badass and what this means to you
personally
this is such a big deal i'm so proud i
could burst what does it mean to you
personally
you know personally it just is a is a
representation of a lot of hard work i'm
on a team when i'm in a board room
i'm not the only one there are amazing
board members around the table
i'm in partnership with kevin johnson
the ceo i'm following in the legacy of
the great
howard schultz who inspires me every
single day
and i think about the work that i need
to do for the partners of starbucks and
for our shareholders
and i'm going to make sure that i work
really hard to be up to the task
and i also understand i need to do a
good job so that there can be more black
women
who are uh chairs of fortune 500
companies
all right it's great news melody awesome
congratulations
it's really cool news thank you